Mike Rowe is a best-selling author Emmy
winner and podcaster best known for his
stint hosting the Discovery Channel's
long-running Dirty Jobs where he
performed the sort of work we all rely
on but don't want to think about too
much from cleaning septic tanks to
putting Hot Tar on roofs to disposing of
medical waste he's done it all and loves
to talk about the value of the hard
honest work that he thinks is devalued
by a society fixated on sending everyone
to college I caught up with row at
Freedom Fest in annual Gathering help
this year in Memphis we talked about how
his micro Works Foundation matches young
people interested in learning trades
with employers dying for applicants why
men continue to fall farther behind
women in school and work and how Noble
whiskey named after Mike's maternal
grandfather is fueling his non-profit's
impact
Mike Rowe thanks for talking to reason
it's been a hot minute man it has been
it's been uh what was it 2016 or 2017.
14 was the first one yeah which I
thought went very well yes 16 again
which modesty aside I thought was even
better okay so my expectation I didn't
even know what to think about what's
about yeah this I'm thinking you know
Spider-Man 3 the third Matrix movie this
is a disaster written all over it but
you don't know right you don't know
where the line is until you go over it
so I think in the spirit of
self-reflection we ought to just check
each other as we go okay do me this
favor if you would yes because I can't
remember if you if I start to tell a
story that I've already told you just
saying this is like the third time
you've said this already so yes is that
all you know uh very good so well what
is your mission these days or or I guess
a better way of phrasing it and I should
have just started with this you know you
kind of emerged as a person talking
about policy on the backs of noting the
tremendous mismatch between the way
we're educating our kids and the economy
that's out there and also what you know
what different kids want
um and you talked about how you've
talked about how we've made work the
enemy about how vocational and Technical
schooling at the high school level has
all but disappeared in a mad rush to
push people into a college track which
however well-intentioned I think we both
obviously benefited from going to
college so it's not either War but it's
left a lot of kids stuck in school that
they don't like and it's left a lot of
employers just kind of like where
where's my work where are my workers
give us an update on how things are
going in terms of the micro Works
Foundation matching you know people who
might be interested in trade jobs and
employers who desperate we need them
well I'm older than I've ever been right
and so that's really the thing
um I said some things to you 10 years
ago and I said some things on Labor Day
of 2008 when we started micro Works
um that have turned out to be kind of
prophetic if I don't say so myself and
um well I'm not going to take a Victory
lap on any of it because some of the
news is bad
by and large the operating thesis has
been borne out we gave College a giant
PR campaign that it really did need
starting back in the 70s but all that
great press came at the expense of
virtually every other form of education
and as a result we created a giant Gap
in the workforce between blue and white
collar jobs white were clearly ascendant
blue was clearly subordinate and the
rift in our Workforce and the labor
shortage that we're seeing today and my
estimation can be walked right back to
the moment we decided to take shop class
out of high school and so many things
followed that as a result one of those
things in a completely tertiary way was
a show called Dirty Jobs which basically
gave me permission to crawl through
sewers and channel my inner
eight-year-old finally yeah right I mean
it was such an odd thing Nick for that
show to happen the way it happened but
to your very kind preface to the
question you posed I didn't really start
looking for a way to articulate a policy
because I had some deeply held belief
and I needed to I needed to be heard
that crazy show blew up and then the
headlines caught up to the themes of the
show so in 2008 Dirty Jobs had been on
for five years Suddenly It's this hit
the country goes into a recession work
Finds Its way into the headlines along
with the skills Gap and people started
to call me to see if I had an opinion
and um I I kind of did but honestly
it wasn't so much of mine as what was
left over from buying lots of beer for
lots of people who we featured on the
show and listening to them uh
complain moan uh and just whacks on
about the challenges of running a small
business that required skilled labor so
after hearing a lot of that micro Works
started and uh today 15 years later
I really haven't changed a thing we're
still saying look the opportunities that
exist are real they're underserved
they're under promoted and the skills
Gap has widened last time we talked
there were 2.3 million open positions
um sorry there were probably close to
four or five in 2016. and these are like
trade jobs well broadly speaking I don't
want to paint with too broad a brush but
of the 11 million open jobs today the
vast majority don't require a four-year
degree they require training right so
does that make them trade jobs not
necessarily but a big chunk of them are
um on the consumer side I think the real
thing that's changed that's alarming and
also was pretty easy to predict
was how long do you want to wait for a
plumber right so the conversation used
to be
let me talk about the myths and
misperceptions that keep people out of
Plumbing so people who might want to
jump into that trade will benefit and
then it was well let's talk about some
of the stigmas and the stereotypes the
key parents and guidance counselors from
promoting these trades because now we're
just getting in our own way yeah today
it's just how long do you want to wait
for a plumber or an electrician today
and this is what I I sort of hoped would
happen because I think it's the final
step in writing the ship we have to have
people who don't work in the trades
or who don't employ trades people to
realize that they nevertheless have skin
in the game right and they have to be a
part of the conversation and that is
like I don't want to wait six months for
a plumber that's right that's when it
gets personal has the plumbing industry
and and maybe other traits you know
carpentry or or you know just
construction things like that have they
changed the way that they go after
workers and do have they made it easier
to enter those trades because depending
on where you live if you live uh you
know as I have it at various points in
the Midwest and small towns you know
getting into something is very different
than I live in New York City now and you
know if there's something harder than
getting into Columbia or NYU it might be
getting into the plumbers Union right so
I mean have have the trades changed the
way that they attract and kind of train
people that's a really interesting point
I hadn't thought about
elitism in the trades in the way that
you know the difficulty of getting into
a certain Union might help set that
table
um I do think broadly things have
changed uh your first point was from a
recruiting proposition are companies
becoming more persuasive in making a
case for themselves and I think they
have but again that's pretty broad some
have for sure some haven't we uh can
learn a lot I think about the recruiting
messages that we see in the armed forces
they're different the Army has a
different proposition than the Navy
they're close the Navy wants you to go
on an adventure the Army wants you to be
all you can be and you'll leave uh
better for it as a result the Coast
Guard I'm not quite sure what they're
saying but it's also a variation on that
thing I suspect the Coast Guard always
has a lot of people going there because
that's the safest branch it feels like
it now the Seabees different deal their
trades right so yeah but all of these
are interesting right till you get to
the Marines who say probably not for you
yeah right right and so there is
something fundamentally interesting
about historically anyway the challenge
of recruiting uh into the Marines versus
everybody else I it might be a bit of a
stretch but I think I think employers
have made a mistake over the years by by
apologizing for their for the
opportunities by saying look it's better
than you think right or it's not as bad
as you've been told and and so
everything just feels
subordinate going in when in fact right
now
and this has changed a lot too we've
we've assisted nearly 2 000 people
through microworks
um we've awarded close to seven million
dollars in work ethic scholarships and
for me Nick the the big change now is
it's not just me older than I've ever
been anecdotally telling you about what
I think might be a good idea for your
kids we can now bring back people who we
have assisted three four years ago and
sit down just like this and I can talk
to them and they tell their story and
when a millennial or a gen Zer here's a
25 year old 26 year old woman talk about
making 160 000 a year welding yeah right
they set up they're just more persuasive
than I am the Optics are better yeah
yeah right and they have more skills
than you I mean you can yeah brutal my
toolbox is a
limited and not a traditional Blue
Collar one but yes they do they're
they're highly skilled and as important
they possess the kind of work ethic that
I think every parent hopes their kids
inherit and certainly every employer
hopes their employees possess let's talk
a little bit about work ethic and I'm
you know like you I I'm an old old
person who's getting older every day
um and you know I don't want to just be
the old man who is like you know from I
can remember you know my little league
coaches My Boy Scout Troop leaders and
so you know who just get apoplectic you
know and it was like you're just an old
man like you're going through male
menopause or something like that I don't
want to be that person but when you look
at questions maybe not a work ethic
because that you start to get into value
judgments but labor force participation
maybe one of the things that is amazing
is that if you the the idea of an
after-school job you know if you're in
high school now if you're 16 years old
you basically don't work
um you know what what went into that why
did those jobs disappear and what are
the effects of
coming out of high school and
increasingly you know people coming out
of college without ever having done even
you know a kind of make work job for
probably for a couple hours a week I
think boy that's a big one part of the
answer has to do I believe with the idea
that we think the lower rungs on the
ladder are somehow less important part
of it has to do with the conversation
we've heard around like the minimum wage
right and so many arguments that attempt
to take an entry-level job that was
never designed to generate enough income
to support you and and and belittle that
opportunity because it's not
a higher rung right and so we we just
entered into this space I think where we
wanted all of the rungs on the ladder to
be absolutely equal and because they're
not we we began to look for scapegoats
right and we we begin to look for
explanations as to as to how these lower
rungs were uh
somehow marginalized right it's just all
it's goofy yeah there's a chronology to
uh to climbing a ladder there's a
chronology to living your life you know
and we're supposed to be smarter as we
get older I hope we are yeah yeah
um but
I don't know I to me the conversations
I've had with a lot of people coming
right out of college is they don't want
to waste their time on the lower rungs
yeah there's an impatience with it
uh and and that's really a shame because
you know the things you can learn
on the lower rungs the things you're
supposed to learn are just are are
manifold I am wondering how much and you
know in the uh interim since we last
talked I uh co-authored a story at
reason about Millennials which uh and
this would have been around uh you know
2015 2016 something like that so around
the time we uh talked and it was very
positive because Millennials were doing
pretty well and they seemed hopeful
um you know things change uh but
um you know I remember writing about how
they were going to be the first
generation in America really deliver on
the American dream where I thought about
my grandparents who were immigrants from
Ireland and Italy came here they left
horrible circumstances came to bad
circumstances but they got to choose
them at least my parents and my aunts
and uncles were raised in you know
immigrant ghettos and then went through
the depression in World War II and it
was was much better but they worked
during the week to have a little bit of
money on the weekend to have fun their
jobs were not fulfilling they did not
expect them to be fulfilling my siblings
and my kind of cousin cohort we more or
less got we had many more options in our
jobs some of for some of us are very
expressive of who we are and what we
want to do but my kids generation you
know and this is I have one Millennial
and one gen Z this is the delivery on
the on the promise that their jobs are
going to really Express who they are and
what they care about fundamentally right
and you know in the time since that
article came out and I talked to a lot
of Millennials in gen Z people who tend
to be very sour and bitter uh and they
feel like they've been lied to and
cheated even before covet after that you
know imagine going to college or trying
to go to work during covet it sucks you
know and like you know you're not going
to die from this disease but somehow you
have to stay at home
Etc and I realized part of it was I was
saying like could you imagine being told
when you're 21 go out and find a job
that expresses who you are and your
deepest commitments right whether
they're political or social or
ideological how the hell did that happen
how did how did work become the primary
metric
the mirror that we hold up it's a it's a
big important part of our lives for sure
yeah but you're so right the the thing I
know I I pushed that into circulation
like I believe that yeah um and I
realize now it's kind of a you know it
was a big miscalculation to expect young
people to know what they wanted to do
and then also be able to do it because
well I you know when I look back at my
my you know entire uh career is a mix of
dirty jobs like of the sort that you
would do and then the kind of
intellectual equivalent of that of
writing for teen magazines and Business
magazines and things that you would
never in a thousand years want to read
yourself right but that's what you do in
order to build the skills so that you
know what you want and you might be able
to get a job doing that sometimes you
know you make little rocks out of big
rocks right sometimes your day might
have felt like drudgery you've probably
written some articles that you actually
didn't give a damn about but major
deadline and you got it done right and
you were able to take some satisfaction
from doing that you know the the irony
is with with Gen Z and again way too
brought a brush but I've hired a few
and around my Foundation you know they
come in knowing that okay well micro
works is trying to close the skills Gap
yeah right micro Works believes that you
know all jobs are opportunities and that
some jobs have gotten short shrift and
they get all that and um six months
later you know they'll come into the
office and I'll say so look um I've been
reading some articles and the skills
gap's not closed yet yeah I I've been
here six months okay
what what's the hold up right and so
it's it's easy to poke fun at that but I
I try not to because it just who gave
them that expectation if these are
snowflakes where are the clouds from
which they fell that that would be us
yeah right totally and so you know
I want to give the benefit of the doubt
to everybody I meet in terms of their
own work ethic I don't want to think of
people as being fundamentally lazy the
problem is they are when I say they I
mean me yeah
this is the Fault in Our Stars we're not
born eager to get up early stay late
volunteer for the crafting jobs
we're Rivers trying to get to the ocean
we got to a mountain we don't go over we
just go around and just keep going
so you know there's a lot of new
research since we spoke last that that
goes to work ethic and goes right to
your point Nick eberstadt wrote a great
book back in 2016 called men without
work and he republished it after the
lockdowns right because it just became
hyper real and super relevant according
to him 7.2 million able-bodied men in
Prime working age are sending out the
workforce you know not not just not
working but affirmatively not looking
for work yeah right that's new that's
never happened in peace time you know
and uh what do you what do you think
goes into that
um like why I mean part of me wants this
you know I I agree it's problematic and
you know in prepping for this I was
looking at Bureau of Labor Statistics uh
labor force participation rights and
this is men and women so it's the whole
Workforce basically the only place where
there are more people of a given age
working than in 20 in 2001 in 2021 or if
you're 55 and older all of the younger
categories there's a smaller percentage
of you know 25 to 34 year olds working
now than in 2001. and it's kind of like
what you know what where is that you
know part of me wants to say well that's
an artifact of wealth uh like you were
saying you know like if you don't have
to work for a living why would you so
we're we're carrying more people right
um but you know then it's kind of
interesting that people over 55 are
hustling more it's an artifact of
comfort for sure yeah I don't know if
it's an artifact of wealth I I do think
that if if we succeed in making work the
enemy right as a society if if we
succeed in identifying the proximate
cause of our misery
as this Antiquated routine of getting up
and driving in and so forth and so on
well then then yeah we're gonna we're
gonna look for any Dodge we can find in
order not to do that
um but you don't have to be wealthy not
to work you just have to be able not to
work in order not to work yeah yeah so
wherever the standard is it's being met
by lots and lots and lots and lots and
so part of that might be you know that
families have a little bit more money so
they're letting kids
you know stick around longer uh without
paying rent or you know leaving the nest
some of it is surely uh you know
transfer payments
um you know I know George W Bush was
assailed as a conservative but he was a
compassionate conservative and when he
took office and you know right around
the time of the tech bubble bursting he
expanded a variety of welfare benefits
that he never really closed so when the
economy took off so people you know were
able to get food stamps were able to get
different and I'm not you know we can
argue about whether or not these are
good things in general but we've as a
society you know both kind of in a
family level and at a governmental level
we support more people not working than
we used to right he also says that
you're you're talking about senior no W
boys that's right now his dad
I believe was the guy who talked about a
thousand points of life that's right
okay one of which we should point out
especially to younger people was
throwing up on a Japanese politician
which is kind of great I think we should
I wish politics and people put a
Japanese politician no but didn't his
son get a shoe thrown at it by a daggery
Japanese reporter well I think it was in
a rainy uh an Iraqi or a middle eastern
are we really going to conflate Japan
and Iraq on this podcast yeah I don't
think I am I don't think I'm going to
okay somebody may have yes
um point being
if we're in a society where a thousand
points of light are real that is to say
you know many many many
charitable Endeavors run by passionate
people who care deeply about improving
life in their zip code right if that's
the world that we're in then we might be
able to look at everstats uh numbers and
go okay
what are these 7.2 million able-bodied
men doing if they're not affirmatively
looking for work might they he said
hopefully be engaged with one of these
points of light might they be doing
something to contribute to society and
ultimately to themselves as a result of
this and unfortunately the data says no
they're not doing that at all what
they're doing is spending over 2 000
hours a year on their screens they're
swiping left they're swiping right
they're tick-tocking they're not they're
they're just doing that thing and look
that might be a little too disparaging
maybe what they're doing on their
screens is taking deep dives into
thoughtful conversations like this one
or taking free courses from MIT yeah I
don't know but whatever it is it's new
whatever they're doing it's not Public
Service it's not work as we understand
it they're they're outside of they're
not even drug dealing for God they're
not even drug dealing it's just not yeah
it's the new level of laziness um you
know to uh drill down on this a little
bit though too like you you started
talking about men and you know Nick
ebersatt's book along with uh Richard
Reeves has a book out
um uh of call of boys and men which also
looks at it let's focus a little bit on
the gender component of this are women
dropping out of the workforce in the
same way I don't know Nick what is a
woman yeah that's true that's a good
question really we're gonna do this yeah
um well I can tell you anecdotally my
Foundation
the the amount of people who apply for
work ethic scholarships there are more
men than women but they're a shockingly
high number of women
and these are for jobs that
traditionally were just considered more
male correct right in fact like welding
is welding's a terrific example
um we just we've been trying to to do a
better job of telling the stories of the
people that I've just mentioned and we
just shot with five of them created Five
PSAs which modesty a cider
terrific
um and my favorite one is with a woman
named Chloe Hudson who applied for a
work ethic scholarship six years ago we
gave her a little bit of money she was
this close to borrowing a few hundred
grand to be the plastic surgeon that she
had always dreamed of becoming
but froze up at the last second is an
awful lot of money and she just didn't
want to do it Flash Forward she is a
rock star right she's just killing it
she everybody loves her she's so good at
what she does what she do she right now
she's working over at uh Joe Gibbs right
so she's working on Race Cars you know
she had worked in various other fields
prior to that but always welding it just
made sense to her which is so
interesting if you if you juxtapose a
plastic surgeon with a welder yeah it's
a different kind of surgery right yeah I
don't know but there's a lot of
similarity well I'll tell you where it
gets dissimilar there's zero debt yeah
there's 160 Grand a year
and there is the abject admiration of
lots of men who look at her and see the
talent that she has she sat just like
we're talking right now and she said I'm
not I'm not the best female welder I'm
not a weld her she doesn't care about
the gender she aggressively doesn't care
about it she cares about the talent yeah
right so you know I'm tempted to say
some some things broadly about what's
going on with with gender in the
workforce but I think the book you
referenced is is on point I think we're
failing our boys badly I think about it
too in terms of when you were talking
about you know we we try to avoid work
if possible I remember a moment I would
hear this from in my relatives and
friends of mine who you know who had
parents and grandparents the same age
and you would always hear the same story
and it finally clicked to me which was
that you know the Depression hit 1929
came and Grandpa could never find work
again but Grandma somehow was like
cooking for people cleaning running a
room a rooming house you know doing all
things and like finally about the 30th
time I heard that I was like how is it
that like women during the Depression
started working like 20 jobs whereas the
men including my father's father just
kind of disappeared and would show up
every once in a while when he sniffed
you know welfare money or a paycheck and
it was like this there's something
different about men I think
um that is disturbing I mean they were
all you know we have the Jughead Jones
trait where we will you know put in as
much time to avoid work as just getting
it done and then getting on with the
rest so what about this what if what if
women in a general way are more like a
general practitioner and what if men in
a general way are more like a specialist
maybe men gravitate toward the kind of
skill that feels like a specialty right
and maybe women historically anyway
because they have to do so many
different things just approach work
from a different angle look I think
I think the I think the modern day
farmer
and the old day Farmer for that matter
are probably the best example of what
I'm talking about it's not a gender
thing it's just this idea that if you're
going to be a successful farmer you
better understand the environment you
better understand ecology you better
understand food science you better
understand Plumbing you better
understand veterinary science but you
have to do a lot of different you also
have to be able to transact like when
you're selling your crops or your you
understand business you better
understand supply and demand you better
you know farmers are plagued by
something really
that almost nobody else is and that's
they over produce they're so good at
what they do they're so efficient right
one and a half percent of the country is
feeding 330 million people three times a
day and the rest of the world yeah and
so you know they have to look at work
differently in in my view and just a
quick sidebar too before I forget I I
think it's so interesting I I learned
years ago a miner told me this he said
with respect to work
there are many many many many many jobs
but there are only two industries
farming and Mining every single thing in
this room in this hotel here at Freedom
Fest every every single thing is either
grown from the ground
and turned into something useful that we
can eat or you know sit in uh or it's
pulled from the ground and fashioned by
a Tradesman into something useful so
those are the only two industries that
that matter everything else becomes a a
more specialized thing you know so maybe
there's something in this idea
of Industries uh versus jobs or careers
versus vocations and and just the way we
think about work when we're young to
your earlier point I mean how did you
think about it in terms of like you when
you were describing your childhood and
your dad's childhood there was adversity
in it there were challenges and things
do you feel like those tempered you in a
way that actually made your parents job
maybe a little easier than it would be
today for a wealthy set of parents you
know yeah I know you know I I think you
know part of it is if you think about
something like Abraham Maslow's
hierarchy of needs you know it used to
be and you know he never used a pyramid
but we're in Memphis named after a city
with pyramids there's a big pyramid
right around the corner from here so I'm
gonna invoke a pyramid but we you know
all of humanity has moved so far up the
pier pyramid that we're all like
pharaohs now nobody is you know nobody's
actually schlepping Rock anymore and as
a result you you know you you become
pickier and choosier and things like
that but to go to your point
um you know when I I went to college
because I didn't want to live with my
parents and I could afford it and I paid
for it myself and then when I graduated
college I would work so I could get
money to travel in a 1970 Plymouth
Valiant that broke down because I
stupidly thought that I could actually
do tune-ups by the way I mean the
Valiant are you kidding me everyone
doesn't buy a car called The yeah well
it was indestructible I found because I
had screwed up the timing belt I'd
ruined virtually every aspect of it but
it would still keep going but I would
work for three months or six months and
then over a number of years I was like
okay well what am I good at and you know
what you know what do I like doing and I
kind of crept into journalism I worked
in Johnson and Johnson personal product
factories I did a lot of horrible jobs
but then it started you know what what I
was good at and what I wanted to do and
what the world would pay me for all sort
of to come into more Focus well let's go
back to your car man because look I
Valiant the coward dies a thousand
deaths yeah the value of but one I mean
never mind the fact that cars used to be
named amazingly cool things now we have
what the probe or whatever it is not
that there's anything wrong with probing
but yeah you don't save my life there
there is something Valiant yeah and
something Noble
about everything you've just described
it's all it's it's rooted in in in
practicality and it's a you know it's
it's the part of the iceberg that you
don't see which incidentally brings me
back to the pyramid right A lot of
people like if you look at those three
pyramids in Egypt have you ever seen the
the imagined uh graphic that shows you
the Subterranean look of what's beneath
the pyramids I I'm afraid to look but
tell me
it's picture of the Washington Monument
like what if the pyramids oh wow are
just the top of the Washington Monument
what if under them are hundreds or
thousands of feet of this this giant
rectangle a pyramid is just the top
right of a thing
but we tend to look at pyramids as this
these Apex of something literally
literally yeah but we don't imagine what
might be under it right right so do you
think then uh that we you know kind of
as a society we've we've lost
you know the process of what goes on
underneath and adds to all of this
including work I mean because you know
when I think about it it's also
um you know the the work that you do or
not maybe not the work the activity you
do maybe in your 20s and I think this is
true on some level of every
socioeconomic level but you wander
around because you don't know who you
are and you're not supposed to know who
you are and you're supposed to go out
and you know have a lot of Adventures
and a lot of experiences and hopefully
that which doesn't kill you makes you a
little bit smarter maybe not stronger
and and you kind of figure out what you
know what path you want to actually take
how many times do you have to touch the
hot stove yeah before you realize that's
not a thing I want to touch well I've
been thinking more actually about the
old uh orange juice concentrate cans in
the freezer and I would touch my tongue
to that every time because I was like
this time it's not going to stay
wow well you know what I mean and here
we are Maslow would have said something
very different about you that's true
that's true
um but yes that's that's it on steroids
we our peripheral vision seems to have
vanished we can only see the stuff
that's right in front of us right we we
can't see a pyramid as anything other
than a three-dimensional triangle that
sits on the ground
um
that's what dirty jobs that might this
is my whole career yeah now that I think
about it I mean celebrating the work
that's out of sight therefore out of
mind which is simply a thing that wasn't
done on TV and then we started to do it
and then a conversation unfolded that
said wait a minute there is an awful lot
of things going on that we can't see
that matter a lot right and so
for me I think everything we're talking
about right now is a mix of two really
interesting things it's the stuff you
can't see that is nevertheless
Australian and then it's the stuff that
is impossible to not see the marketing
the pr the name of the car the Valiant
right all of that that thought that goes
into branding work all that thought that
goes into promoting opportunity that's
PR in its purest form so when you have
something that that's that overt trying
to make a persuasive case for the part
of the pyramid you can't see you've got
a a pretty interesting challenge right
you know it's a pretty interesting
balance but if you only look
at at the surface the promoy thing then
I think you wind up kind of where we are
now with millions of jobs that have
great opportunities attached to them
that people are highly skeptical of
right right so you know a more balanced
conversation might lead to a more
balanced Workforce so do you I mean have
you talked to
education associations or school I mean
is there is there a move towards you
know more vocational training and that's
even you know that's the wrong term for
this
um you know fewer people are going to
college uh I was just looking at the
numbers in 2019 about 66 of high school
graduates immediately went on to some
form of higher ed
and it is down in 2021 to 62 so it's
decline covet I'm sure is part of that
uh you know various factors go into that
but it's still and if you go back to
1970 with something you know it was like
I think under 50 of people immediately
went out to college so we're in you know
a peak period but you know have you
talked to high school people uh or you
know are they changing the curriculum or
the way that they talk about what do you
do when you graduate from the
conversations definitely changed uh but
again in Pockets a lot of a lot of this
is geographical as for the curriculum
you know my Foundation now has a
curriculum that's in 20 schools um we
hope to get in many many more that's a
that's a tough sell yeah you know for
for all sorts of reasons
um so
I don't know on a macro level really
where we are with this but I do know
that when we started I talked to some
Educators in um Peoria and you know
you're making that up I swear I'm not
okay because caterpillar yeah was a was
an early partner right and there they
are yeah this is a classic like cat's a
great case study for a company that is
constantly trying to recruit for great
jobs that people don't think are great
jobs and part of the reason Nick is
because guidance counselors in their
very Hometown they're in Illinois the
proposition to a kid is okay before
you're over here you know we've got
opportunities over here and if you don't
do this and if you don't do that you
know what you're going to wind up doing
you're going to wind up turning a wrench
over at the Cat dealer down the road you
don't want to do that right yeah well
guess what the Cat dealer down the road
turn the wrench is killing it yeah it
basically set his own hours at this
point some reunion some are not it
depends but but that's what I mean it's
like the the perception
really is very granular and it's very
it's show me a guidance counselor who's
doing it right and I'll show you one
who's getting it wrong yeah I don't I
don't know what the research really says
honestly in a in a broad way but I can
feel it tipping and I also don't know
how to react when you say that fewer
people are going to college now right
because my gut wants to high-five you my
gut wants to say great 1.7 trillion
dollars in student loans a huge number
of those people you referenced who go to
college don't finish like maybe half
you know are they bundled into that
number you know the first time we talked
you asked me a great question and it
you asked me to explain the fact that so
many kids who graduated from college by
and large were making a Better Living
than those who who didn't go to college
and who just had High School
and uh whatever answer I gave you I
thought about it later and I was like no
crap the better answer is most of those
charts in fact I've never seen one that
has as part of the rubric
a cohort of people who finished high
school but went on to master a skill
that was in demand
by any right it could be an
apprenticeship program could be a trade
school whatever it was
that cohort is never represented and
what I've realized since our earlier
conversations and now that the
foundation's 15 years old
is that's where we live we're looking
for people
education is not the enemy the four-year
school is not the enemy we both
benefited I think from a liberal arts
degree tremendously yeah I got mine at
84. I'm guessing you were there at 85.
85 yeah and I worked for a while and
then I went to grad school and got a
master's and a PhD look at that yeah
total cost of your education if you had
to back the envelope you know uh uh
let's say probably I mean in
contemporary dollars it would no back
then oh uh you know I it's hard to say
because I got financial aid and I worked
and I took out a few amount of loans but
I came out of a PhD with my PhD
including uh undergrad uh maybe ten
thousand dollars in debt total in debt
my entire thing uh two years of
Community College year off back to
school got a BS in Communications and
some other minors and whatever I think
the whole thing the whole thing was
twelve thousand nine hundred dollars
today same schools same course loads 92
Grand right so yeah I mean good God it's
uh so so when you tell me fewer people
are going to college I I'm I'm glad but
I'm not glad because I'm anti-college
and I'm not glad because I'm
anti-education you just hate those kids
I just hate those specific children no
but it is a kind of interesting question
right to ask I think so are those the
people who aren't going to college are
they doing something else or are they
just hitting the next level you know in
in Minecraft or World of Warcraft or
something like that right and look it's
I don't think it's fair or or nice even
to compare
a liberal arts degree to a skilled trade
I just think the proposition is
different but it but it is fair to say
that I can I can get the exact
equivalent of a liberal arts degree if
I'm curious and I have an internet
connection yeah not a smartphone right
99 of the known information in the world
is now in my pocket yeah and I can
access it whenever I want that wasn't
the case in 1984 for me so the access to
the information is different if I may I
would also say for me and I suspect this
is true a lot of people
um you know in in a similar boat going
to college among other things gave me an
appreciation for The Wider world oh yeah
if I hadn't gone to college
you know I don't know like I I might
have ended up working near my hometown
or in a a sub trade job because the idea
of being a carpenter or a mechanic you
know and and everybody can thank me for
not going into either of those fields
given my you know 10 thumbs uh you know
but like saying like oh well you know
what you can make something out of your
life and by that I don't mean like how
you get to do this or that but it's like
it's you can choose your own adventure
yeah which is really important I think
and that can be one of the great goals
of Education you don't hear much about
that anymore when people talk about
college now it's you go there in order
to make 90k you know within two years of
graduating or this or that or having
that credential
um which I think is a loss it's
understandable because the price goes up
and also when you have second and third
and fourth generation kids going to
college you know the parents aren't
going to sit around and my father didn't
graduate high school he literally had no
idea what I did in college he when my
older brother who was a National Merit
scholar like he was a really smart guy
my parents were like well you're going
to college but they did they were like
you know how do you do that they didn't
they knew people got into college but
they didn't know how right um so but but
that that's the point of the liberal
arts to me that was what the transaction
was about you're a curious person and
we're going to satisfy your curiosity
we're going to encourage you to study
all kinds of different things right that
you may or may not be interested in and
then when we're done with you you'll get
your paper but you're not going to be
qualified to do anything right what
you're going to be is a better
well-rounded person more so than you
were when you went in and then you're
going to get yourself hired somewhere
and then you're going to learn a
practical skill right that's how it
always tracked for me now though
is the kind the pressure for a kid to
declare a major the pressure to declare
and announce the road you're going to go
down and it's it's very hard to get off
of that road and so if you choose poorly
at 17 or 18. you're locked into a
nightmare you're not just like it's not
just a nightmare it's a it's a it's a
very pricey fever dream yeah right and
you can't now you're protecting your
investment now you've got now you're
holding the paper maybe you owe your dad
maybe you love Freddie or Fannie Mae
whatever it is
it's so so hard for kids
to go the other way now after we spoke
in 2016 there was a presidential debate
big one you'll remember all 17 oh yes
luminaries up there right it was like a
mini series I think it's still going on
it's good it would help us Marco said
something in response I forget what the
question was but he said what this
country needs
are more welders and fewer philosophers
yeah big Applause line and later that
evening on my little social channels I
mean thousands of people are saying hey
Mike this guy's singing your song yeah
this this guy gets it
and I thought oh crap I'm I'm doing
something wrong because that's not at
all what I mean all right that's the
binary thought right you know what I
responded to uh in the wake of that was
look
what our country needs are more welders
who can talk intelligently about
Descartes and Nietzsche yeah and what
our country needs are more philosophers
who can run an even bead yeah right it's
not this or that that's that blue-collar
white collar trap right thing like you
if you're not this you must be that
that's not no that's probably that's a
great point and I mean if anything one
would hope that the 21st century
whenever it gets started is going to be
different it's not going to be binary
like the 20th century was Labor versus
management you know these are idiotic
oppositions that serve nobody but you
know Democrat versus Republican liberal
versus conservative like we are digging
into binaries that made the 20th century
in many ways uh fantastic you know the
best Century so far but also a hellhole
right because it's how do you think the
whole work from home phenomenon right
now fits in with that that that feels
like a new thing that's really defining
people and separating people I think it
during covid it was a very Stark uh
distinction you know the kind of what
was called the laptop class or the
bathrobe class
um I found it a kind of uh revolting in
the sense of uh
you know for those of us who could work
from home and you know I was able on
Amazon I was able to buy a higher
resolution uh web cameras and and I was
able to do many more video uh interviews
you know because everybody was around
and I knew a lot of people in my
circumstance who were like let's not
rush back to work you know we don't you
know we can wait this out and this was
right they had no idea who was
delivering the packages that were you
know showing up magically at their door
every day and it was kind of amazing to
see that kind of divide and I find that
you know deeply troubling because this
goes to your point that like a lot of us
are not thinking about okay how does the
whole system work we only see the things
that's right or you know that we want to
see
um having said that I've been working
from home I've been telecommuting as it
used to be called since about 1996. I've
had stints in offices since unreason has
a big office in DC
um but
um I am of a mixed mind I think again
it's kind of a reversion to the 19th
century you know where most people
before factories most people worked from
home and you have the same nightmare you
know when you wake up in your workplace
your Hearth is you know you know you get
out of bed and there you are in your
workplace it's like it's a little bit
you know tough
um but I do think what we're seeing is a
shift away from strictly markations
between work and non-work and life and I
think they prose they pose certain types
of challenges because you do it is kind
of nice to have an office that's away
from your home so that you're keeping
things a little bit different but it's
also it's a melding that is quite good
and we need to start coming up with
better ways of thinking about this stuff
so that we organize it so it doesn't all
slop into one another have you heard the
back and forth between
um Elon Musk and Kevin O'Leary on this
musk is basically saying this is a moral
issue yeah
get to work this is a it's morally wrong
for a giant chunk of the workforce to
work from home simply because a they can
or B they want to that's not the deal
right it's a hell of a thing right
O'Leary is saying
that's stupid you have to adapt and
adopt and play the cards we have and you
just gave millions of people a taste of
something they want more of right so I
have 54 companies that I run and I the
majority of them are not coming yeah in
fact none of them are coming to work
every day some are coming half the time
and many aren't coming at all but
they're all getting their work done and
so forth and so on but and this is
you'll love this O'Leary then says but
when I have a question I call them
and maybe it's two in the morning tough
yeah maybe they're on vacation I
don't care right if you're gonna do this
then if if you're gonna blur the work
life line right as an employee then I'm
gonna blur it as an employer and you are
now a doctor on call with a pager in
1980 and I'm running the hospital right
and that made me think oh well then that
at least
now we have a pendulum swinging both
ways and now would the person who would
prefer to work from home be comfortable
with that new distinction or would they
say no no I want it to be just like it
was when I was at the office but I don't
want to be at the office right so I I
think it's a conversation worth having I
agree and I mean this is you know this
is how things evolve and change and the
Technologies and the organizations that
last are the ones that you know kind of
figure out how to benefit people more I
know when I I moved from Los Angeles to
a small town in Texas a prison town in
fact in Texas yeah you should write
brochures yeah uh and um come to what
was the name of the town Huntsville
Texas oh Huntsville yeah now with
prisons terrific yes that's right you
know now with well it always had prisons
it was built in order to kind of house
prisoners but in any case when I moved
from LA to Texas I was like I am never
going to work again like because I can
work from home why would I ever do any
work and it turned out to be the exact
opposite and I think this is pretty
common where I had a home office
and I had a fax machine a plain paper
fax machine which was like unbelievable
that like look at me you know the son of
peasants owning a plain paper fax
machine in like 1996 and every time I
could hear the fax machine click on yeah
I would like I could be deep asleep I
could be out in the backyard cutting the
grass you know with no earphones on or
anything and I would immediately be in
and making sure that that wasn't the
most important facts of my life of my
work life and so it takes a while to get
all of this stuff right right and it I
mean it takes decades and Society is
just like individuals have learning
curves but I'm glad to hear that Kevin
O'Leary is pushing back on you know the
idea of okay the emergency is over so
now we should return back to you know a
1950s IBM a t model of work
right
um you know but it's not all fun and
games yeah I I don't know that it was
but it was the thing that
evolved naturally from that which
preceded it and to to argue that that's
going to be the way it always is forever
and ever amen well that or that that's
the golden age to which we must return
fire I mean this is the you know what I
think is so great about the current
moment we live in for all of the
problems and whatnot as just said the
proliferation of choices and options
that individuals get to make yeah about
how to live their life about where to
live about what work to do uh you know
even even to work is fantastic it's a it
can be overwhelming we all have moments
uh I'm sure you remember the uh
oh God it was a Robin Williams movie
Moscow on the Hudson where he plays uh a
saxophone player from the Soviet Union
who escapes and comes to New York and
then is like gobsmacked when he's
standing in a grocery aisle and I think
it's all of the different types of
toothpaste I can't believe it yeah
that's the boy Yeltsin moment yeah he's
paralyzed by the amount of choice and I
think sometimes that happens to us as a
society but then the if the if the
response to that is like we got to shut
down choice and we have to have two or
three networks two or three types of
jobs two or three genders even and
that's it like we're doing it wrong well
you have to look in that movie
the the scales fell from his eyes but
only when he saw the totality of the
choices right and it and it happened too
with when Boris Yeltsin walked into that
uh it was a Randall's Supermarket wow in
Texas right he you know he was still
very much the Soviets guy and he was
finishing his tour here it was pudding
pops he saw the pudding pops and he wept
for his people because around the
pudding pops was all that fresh produce
and yeah it was just everywhere no and
he he later wrote that's that's when I
knew we're just Dead Men Walking we
we're not going to win this we can't you
know but it comes from seeing the thing
that's underneath the pyramid it comes
from seeing he had to see it a guy at
that level
still yeah it wasn't enough to hear
about the prosperity and this was
Yeltsin this is Boris Yeltsin wow yeah
and I I guess that's why he started
drinking so much well sure uh and and
drinking a rich variety of juices
available at Randall's now on sale and I
this is a good way to segue into
something uh that I want to talk with
you about which is your whiskey line oh
okay and and one of the reasons why I
want to talk about that is because I was
looking at the way that you guys promote
it and the way that you talk about it
and whatnot and you have a bit on the
website about like our story and it was
your uh it's it's called Noble whiskey
yeah uh
k-n-o-b-e-l and that's your
grandfather's name yeah that's my
thought
um and could you tell the story of that
because what I think is beautiful about
it is that it's a tribute to the past
but it's also something very modern and
kind of forward
yes um Carl Noble was a magician who
lived next door to me where I grew up he
also happened to be my grandfather and
um when I say magician I don't he didn't
pull rabbits out of hats but
he got up clean
wandered out into the world came home
dirty and as a result something was
fixed something was better he could take
your watch apart and put it back
together blindfolded same thing with a
combine he could build a house without a
blueprint he was that guy he only went
to the seventh grade
but he had this he had the chip right
and uh I was pretty sure I was going to
follow in his footsteps because I wanted
to I really really wanted to and when
you're 13 well that's your passion and
you follow your passion and you know but
of course the handy Gene is recessive as
as you certainly know and um and so I
had to get a different toolbox and it
was my pop who said do that get a
different toolbox you can be a Tradesman
you can just that's a state of mind but
find something I don't care who cares if
you're passionate about it just find
something you're good at and figure out
how to love it right so that's the best
advice I ever got and that got me in
entertainment and way leads on to way
and the next thing I knew I was 42 and
he was dying well he was 90 and my
mother called me I was working for CBS
and she said you know your your
grandfather is 90 years old he's not
going to be around forever wouldn't it
be great if before he died he could turn
on the TV and see you doing something
that looked like work
and the next day I took a cameraman into
the sewers of San Francisco and that's
how dirty jobs started
uh five years later
micro Works started when our economy
went into a recession and dirty jobs was
a giant hit and I wanted to do something
with these good cards I got and try not
be a completely rapacious capitalist and
give something back so the TV show Dirty
Jobs and the foundation micro Works were
both dedicated to Carl Noble he only had
girls and when he died he got a weird
name and his name died with him and then
the crazy thing happened that I want to
talk to you about around essentiality
and the notion of essential work because
when we lock down a couple years ago
that expression got dragged back into
the headlines right right essential
essential non-essential exactly and man
was this a an eye-opener for me because
Dirty Jobs was the grandfather of
essential working shows and the pressure
uh the enthusiasm really from fans
saying bring the show back
and the network was into it and I was
into it so I started filming dirty jobs
again during the lockdown and to sort of
commemorate The Madness of that decision
both because I swore I was done in 2012
and because I'm going out to film at the
precise moment when we were at the
height of our
the sum of all fears yeah right so I
wanted to to do a show about essential
work when we were locked down not
because
not because I thought that these jobs
are more essential than than your job or
any other job but because I realized in
that moment that all work is essential
there is no such thing as a
non-essential job because everybody's
essential to somebody
so I had a little peripatia there in the
midst of my uh quasi-retirement and I
went back to work and I thought you know
what better way to celebrate all this
than put my grandfather's name on some
really decent five-year-old Tennessee
whiskey that came to my attention you
know you can't just launch a whiskey
brand that's five years old you have to
find the juice and throw a weird set of
circumstances I got a line on it I told
myself if it tastes good I'm gonna go
for it and it tasted good so I started
selling it as a fundraiser for
microworks online we've been doing it
for a year and a half the feedback's
been great and now I'm in the freaking
Whiskey Business Nick
so one of the things that's fascinating
is I mean that's a way of telling a
story about the past
that is not it doesn't trap us in the
past because one of the other things I
mean I think America is a kind of
concept has always struggled with the
past where we're proud of it or we look
at a revolutionary route but then we're
also ashamed rightly of all sorts of
terrible things that happened in the
past and the the question is how do you
pay respect in the past without being
trapped you know how are you informed by
the past but not
trapped it so that man that that really
gets that gets to it because when Trump
said
let's make America great again
the opposition
really didn't have too much of a choice
other than to take the position that it
was never great in the first place right
and so they did and suddenly things got
reduced into such a horrible binary
where you know a lot of my friends who
were very very anti-trump were suddenly
making arguments I know they didn't
really believe right because the
proposition the table had suddenly been
set to prove that America was not
exceptional to prove that this country
was never great right that that's what
he forced them to do they didn't have to
do it right but but they took it they
took the bait so that's what you're
by the way to be fair the same thing is
true of black lives matter right yeah
when people told me that black lives
matter and when and when they said it
with passion and maybe even shook their
finger I found myself going well
duh I know that
you know why why are you telling me a
thing that I know and and I and I
suddenly found myself saying things like
well all lives matter which of course
became heretical right and deeply
insulting but like that's how we do it
right we we we grab a bromide we turn it
into a platitude and then we got a
megaphone and we scream it and we force
people to take positions they normally
wouldn't take I think that's kind of
right how do you how do you venerate how
do you elevate the past without turning
it into a one-dimensional mythology
and the honor honestly the only way I
can think of to do that is to make sure
you look at what's under the pyramid and
tell both sides now I'm trying to sell
some whiskey so I'm not going to tell
you about my grandfather's shortcomings
I'm not going to tell you about his
disappointments because that's just bad
marketing but if I were really sitting
down with you over a beer and trying to
express the the measure of the man
well then we would
you would hear The Good the Bad and the
Ugly no you'd hear the whole you'd hear
the rest of the story right right yeah
and so you know I
when I write stories on my podcast I I
still try to do that I I try and leave
you I try and make you a little
uncomfortable by reminding you that
Hitler
like to paint
and he loved dogs he's a real animal
lover right so you know it's fun to
create cognitive dissonance in in
people's minds bad guys don't always
twirl their mustaches and wear black
hats and good guys right yeah yeah so
that's I think what you're asking you
know how do you how do you tell the
truth how do you get at the truth of a
thing without becoming an apologist
right or becoming where it's just a
scorched Earth chart you know policy so
that nothing good has happened in the
past or all all of our Idols have feet
of clay and then don't you think today
though too that I mean we're like the
only way to to be credible today is to
speak hard truths to your own tribe
God I hope so I mean I feel like that's
kind of in short supply at least in
terms of you know political discourse we
haven't been seeing that and as a result
I think Republicans and Democrats are
you know there are two uh preoccupied
with you know scorching the other side
than actually kind of doing the internal
work to say like hey maybe we we need a
new script because right neither of them
is doing particularly well with voters
right owning the libs yeah I mean it's
fascinating to me that somebody like Joe
Biden has the same approval rating right
now in his presidency that Donald Trump
had at this point and that's not good
you know that it's not good for either
of them but it's definitely not good for
America right no because we government
in a lot of ways is like TV you know we
we get what we deserve yeah the one
better TV watch better TV that's right
want better candidates vote for better
candidates yeah and so forth so yeah I I
I think I was just thinking of Bill
Maher when you said that you know would
be Bill Maher he's somewhat famously
said I didn't leave the Democratic party
the Democratic party left me and now
suddenly my news feed is carpet bombed
with him saying things that I find
myself agreeing with yeah rezod he's I
mean he's an interesting character who
has I think started to do work where
he's less worried about the other side
and is kind of like working through his
own you know uh complications and I I
think that's a good thing I think it
it's certainly a model for media people
to be doing right rather than just kind
of you know constantly trying to throw
people off balance by attacking the
other side so what's your plan then I
mean what's the what's the role of well
I'm gonna run I'm going to announce my
presidential run and do it now do it do
it to me because I think this
conversation with your permission I'm
going to share it with my yeah
that way you need you need like you need
to low best rated show that you can have
well it's important everything else
looks good yeah you know it's like you
don't know how high you can soar until
you know how low you can go if if you
want to soar with the Eagles you must
wallow with the pig that's right yeah
um well what I was going to ask you
about because uh my career at reason and
I'm actually coming up on 30 in October
I'll have been a reason for 30 years
reason was founded in 1968 and in that
uh you know in that uh workspan I've
done a lot of different things I started
as an assistant editor I became
editor-in-chief of the print magazine
and of the website I helped launch our
video platform
um you know and I like almost every
seven or eight years I would change my
job and that was interesting and one of
the things that reason has been able to
do over the past 30 years or so is to
kind of go with the uh dispersion of old
style media you know we work broadly
speaking in an industry where there were
you know three Giants right there you
know I mean it sounds like 1984 or
something like that but you know there
were three continents now there are a
million different Empires many of which
haven't even been mapped yet and it
seems to me your career
follows that track too because you
started at places like you mentioned CBS
you worked at QVC which was really kind
of a game changer when it came around
you were on the Discovery Channel which
now seems to be an abatement even as
Discovery owns like half of the cable
more than you know box right yeah but
cable is also disappearing and you seem
to have found a life I think you started
doing it on Facebook a kind of direct to
audience storytelling and whatnot and
you know where do you go from that
because you are moving into like you
know wherever the sun is kind of
sweeping you're you're getting there
first no and I mean I find that
fascinating well you know it thanks I
mean it it does feel sometimes when I
when I look back at it that I was ahead
of the curve a little bit but lately
I've really been feeling like I'm I'm
behind it in the sense that cable is
Contracting streaming is just that's a
tie tiger by the tail right everything
is changing certainly the news business
is changing sub stack I think is going
to be a very very big deal
um you know some of the people here at
Freedom Fest shellenberger Matt taibi
right Barry Weiss these are the
journalists of our time yeah and they're
reporting on a platform
that is just growing with more and more
credibility and it's fascinating to
think of somebody like Matt Thai being
Barry Weiss who left you know taibi left
Roman Stone which is you know like wow
that's amazing Barry left the New York
Times because she said you know I think
you know both famously and also rightly
that she didn't want to spend her life
trying to reform something she wanted to
build her own yeah you know institution
and it's easier to do that than ever and
it does change you know the number of
people you reach the intensity of the
relationship except I mean it has a lot
of Ripple effects yeah it does well what
what happened to me really was I I
lucked out so much in that I was able to
keep a foot in both worlds so I did
really well in cable right
um and I've I've been working for
Discovery since 1993. like you that's 30
years yeah you know I don't know how
many different shows there was only one
well two big ones Dirty Jobs and
Deadliest Catch yeah you know both have
been on the air 20 years you know one is
still in production
um so like I've been I was I you know I
pitched Deadliest Catch a Predator but
it never took off
you know what I'll talk to your agent if
you want because I think you know I
think I think there's something there
yeah to catch a deadly predator oh that
would be very good I see yeah it is and
then is a dirty job to catch it Daddy
deadly predator is a dirty job
especially if you're naked and afraid
that's right down under
right you did you did a season in
Australia it's a dirty down under yeah
yeah you you were looking for The Facts
of Life girl and growing pains she's
never I went everywhere okay she's not
there
um but I'll tell you what is there uh
the the same level of curiosity and
enthusiasm for this topic yeah and it it
did remind me that it's it's one of the
truly Universal things people can talk
about so that's where I got lucky my pop
whose name is now on a bottle of whiskey
gave me some excellent advice and what
it turned into was a chance to ruminate
on work and that changed this sounds
impossibly Grand but it changed cable
there are over 30 shows I could draw a
straight line yeah to Dirty Jobs right
so it's a it's this big giant topic and
I never wanted to leave cable because I
was prospering in being there but
yeah uh seven and a half million people
on a Facebook page you can't ignore
um I'm very mindful of that did a show
for Facebook did 100 episodes of
returning the favor
um but I never did what you know Dave
Rubin is doing I never did what the guy
on the what's his name Sean Evans on the
hot ones you know where Rick piatto on
on yeah yeah like I really enjoy those
programs and and I and I've really
admired their ability to to carve out a
platform with no network oversight at
all it's their advertisers and of course
you know they're they're Masters at
YouTube you have to be careful you can
blow yourself up still but in relative
terms it's a it's a much much more
targeted way to to reach your audience
you of course are doing the same thing
right and so yeah I mean it's analogous
for sure here's a question do you worry
about
um and and this is something where I
think we might be at the right hinge
point where I know I don't worry about
it that much younger people do and older
people do where you'll you'll hear
people say well you know we don't have
anything in common because everybody is
narrow casting you know you watch the
things that you like I watch things that
I like and everybody else and like we
have maybe one or two things in common I
don't worry about that partly because I
remember what it was like listening to
the AM radio which and honest you know
In fairness was remarkably diverse
um you know so because you know if there
were six people in the car and maybe one
in the trunk you you know like it had
every seven songs had to cycle through
every possible audience segment but
having said that you know just feeling
totally stultified by turning on ABC NBC
and CBS
um you know or you know list you know
just everything was so narrow sure
because you know so like I don't miss
that but I'm curious do you miss that
kind of scent you know Common text that
we all
you know participate in well I think
what I hear you saying is that well the
thing I miss is the shared experience of
many many millions of people
like the next the day after the Super
Bowl we all have something to talk about
and you know must see TV on Thursday
nights yeah you know that that kind of
who did you miss Wings you know come on
eat wings right I forgot about it but
you're right I I watched every episode
yeah
um but yeah that that seems to be
missing so we're in our silos a little
bit more right but I don't know that
it's a uh as long as we have something
large and biggish and on a selfish level
I'm not too worried about it because I
I this sounds vainglorious but I have a
brand you have a brand
after 30 years of doing this Nick
Gillespie is
it in my mind a mix of skepticism and
reasonableness that's your brand
right sorry and a snappy dresser
yeah yeah I was going for like aging
backwards but you know well Benjamin
Button on us yeah
um but but but that's a broad brand
right and it's very much for sale today
because we need in my view we need a lot
of skepticism my brand is just more of a
good natured of vuncular curiosity
around what people do for for money and
a bit of a philanthropic attempt to to
assist if I can be of use right but but
those things can apply all over the
place so if you're asking on a on a on a
business level on a selfish level I
don't worry at all
um
if you're asking me as a consumer
then yeah I
I feel I guess it's like what do they
call it falma fear of missing out yes I
think we're in the Golden Age of
Television right now this is television
I I stumbled across a show not long ago
called the offer okay the making of The
Godfather right it's on Paramount plus I
had to subscribe and I watched it and it
was so daggone good it made me anxious
about what else is out there that I'm
missing and it's a lot I just watched
something called the the jury which is
terrific yeah I have watched that myself
yeah every single person's an actor
except one dude on the jury and he turns
out to be like Jimmy Stewart yeah he
restores your faith in humanity but but
we have the breakout star of that which
sounds ridiculous to say but it's James
Marsden yeah the only guy who's already
yeah who plays a great parody version of
I hope it's a parody version of himself
I hope it is too I haven't seen it done
that well since uh Matt LeBlanc yes in
episode that's right yeah played a
version of himself which seemed pretty
real yes so um my point is there's a
weird level of anxiety when you discover
how much good stuff there is how many
good bands have you never heard how many
great books have you never read and now
how many wonderful podcasts yeah who the
hell they're three million podcasts out
there mine's pretty good yours is
terrific Joe Rogan talks for three and a
half hours at a time and there's more
listeners at the end than when he
started I mean it's so that's that's
what they say yeah exactly that's what
they're doing they're just they're on
their screen they're listening to Rogan
they're not working but supplements or
psilocybin
that's not a bad way to be you know it's
not bad yeah but so where does that end
though uh or you know Earth I guess
here's a question for you maybe this is
a way to kind of this conversation uh
like one of your shows one of your
series could go on yeah
um but
what um we are in a funk as a society I
think like that and I think back uh you
know I've referenced my parents a bit I
can remember them talking about when you
know the war ended my father had fought
in World War II he landed in in Normandy
he was a Purple Heart recipient Etc but
you know when when the war ended they
were like okay good well we're not at
War anymore but we're just going to be
poor for the rest of our lives because
you know they grew up for then the
Depression hit and then like during
World War II everything was rationed and
you know it was like kind of a shitty
existence and they were like okay well
we're just gonna you know that's what
it's gonna be sure and then by 1950 they
were like you know what something had
changed and like suddenly almost
everybody could become middle class or
you could rise from where you were the
world got richer the 50s is a decade
filled with anxiety and hysteria you
know both about juvenile delinquents and
and homosexuals and you know civil
rights rights and Communists and all
this but people got on with their lives
and kind of were enjoying themselves in
a way that they had in five years before
I remember you know the difference
between about 1979 and 1984 something
happened you know and part of it is you
know part of it is related to politics
and policy part of it is just things
change but I feel like we're in a funk
and we have been for most of this
Century actually yeah you know because
of 9 11 I mean and actually maybe even
because of the the tightness of the gore
Bush election that kind of like people
are like holy cow like we are we just
making this stuff up you know where
everything is down to the flip of coin
but then 911 you know the financial
crisis the rise of trump to some degree
and covid certainly how do we how do we
get out of this funk if like a lot of
what we've been talking about is like
you know what there's a lot of really
good stuff going on people have more
autonomous me people can choose their
Adventures there's more good stuff out
there to to drink and to watch you know
and to drop you name it yeah um but you
know well you start we're all sour you
you start with that you know something
provocative like there's never been a
better time in the history of the world
and to drink my whiskey then right now
uh why wait no look it's a it's an
amazing time to be alive
um if if you're gonna get sick you're
might as well get sick in this country
today this is it
um and so forth and so forth you know
you don't want to be Pollyanna about it
but it's important to say that yeah I
also think it's important to know or at
least to acknowledge that I agree with
every single thing you've said as you
look back through that time period but I
would I push back a little and say I'll
find you're 60 years old now right I'm
about to be congratulations I'll bet you
I could find a 60 year old man in of
those periods you described
who feels exactly the way you feel now
because in relative terms yeah what
you've just done is look back and apply
your own experience to a timeline right
that I'm very familiar with I'm in
violent agreement with everything you're
saying but a genzir couldn't give a crap
it means nothing yeah to them they're
they're right where we were when we were
18. when things were pretty screwed up
when we were 18 geopolitically they were
there were challenges there were all
kinds of things to worry about for sure
I mean for me I think about it and I you
know this is why I think the the story
of the whiskey kind of stuck with me but
my parents were like oh well when I was
21 I went to Normandy and not on
vacation
you know uh you know we were poor we
didn't have clothes we didn't go to
college et cetera and that you know the
kind of memory of uh of poverty in
America which was broad-based it it gave
me like okay whatever however bad things
might be you know right at least I'm not
that but whatever relative analysis
you're conducting you're doing it at a
time in your life yeah that is singular
and today you're at a different time
you've got more experience you've got
all sorts of other things to process but
I will say this I do
I do think we're in a funk and part of
the funk could be
the the siloing that we were talking
about Faith Popcorn was oh wow yeah you
know her yeah the the brand forecaster
yes yeah yeah so the popcorn report yeah
predicted Trends and uh she predicted
something called uh cocooning right
right where basically she pre-saged this
time when you know people would start
delivering food to us and we would have
less and less reason to leave our homes
um and of course she was awfully right
about that yeah um and it changed the
size of the homes we live in it changed
all sorts of things
but then I remember she came out and she
said
cocooning is is so
1985 now it's burrowing now we're not
just in our cocoons yeah we're going
deep because the remote the access to
all of the great entertainment that's
we've just programmed our whole entire
lives so part of why we're in a funk is
probably because we're just inside too
much looking at screens right it just
could be that simple we've cocooned
ourselves yeah you know I was going to
say that about the uh the screen stuff
you know one of the things that's
interesting is that there's a move uh
that I've been following which I find
really fascinating in the Arts in
particular like in painting and
sculpture to really kind of do things
that bring the audience out more because
you can access everything via screens
and it's great it's liberating it opens
up the world but you know more and more
people want to be in a room where
something is happening around them yeah
and with other people well why are we
here I mean yeah Freedom Fest yeah I
mean you know 5 000 people who have
something in common one want to be
together you can't have a festival alone
right I mean you can but it's kind of
but that immersive uh you know
crowd-based uh creation of meaning uh
you know where it's the art isn't
happening on the wall or on the screen
it's happening among the people
connecting yeah I find that fascinating
I do too and and I know how enriched and
nourished I feel after an experience
like that but you're talking about a
funk yeah you know and I I think I
remembered now what I wanted to say it's
the it's it's not a new idea but it's
the it's the collapse of our
institutions you know and and it's the
trust yeah like we
we need to be skeptical that's why I'm a
fan of of your brand but to encourage
skepticism today is to encourage a form
of uh of denying and there are a lot of
people
like I this whole Kennedy thing you know
I'd like I'd love to get Robert F
Kennedy Jr right has has uh has got a
lot of people
all twisted up right and a lot of
different ways and I heard a guy I
respect
um Sam Harris making sense right he's
got a podcast and he listened to Kennedy
on on Rogan and basically said that he
wouldn't have him on his podcast at
least not at this point because he
didn't want to platform ideas that he
believed were fundamentally
irresponsible
and I was so struck by that because I
think
I think what Sam might be missing in
this
is
this default that we've always had back
in the simpler time that you described
when the initials behind a person's name
really were important you know a
scientist with Bona fides mattered
expertness yeah mattered and so the the
trust that we we had in our medical
community and in our political class
you know I mean that that was never
super high but it's never been lower
than right now absolutely so it's just
it's been a straight line decline you
know gallop and Pew and a couple other
places have been tracking trust and
confidence in American institutions
particularly government you know for
more than 50 years and it's just almost
a straight line decline
that's that's honestly Nick what I think
and that is if I may that I think it's
totally legitimate because when you look
at you know if you take the federal
government you know Washington DC since
1968 or 1972 or whenever you know they
have done everything possible to abuse
our trust and confidence in them it's
like they're double dog dare you it's
like and they're like okay well we got
away with that you know no I mean the
the Office of the President had more
trust and confidence in it when Nixon
resigned than it has now and probably
for good reason right but we can't rest
there right because if you go I write a
lot about this if you go from a high
trust Society to a low trust Society
Things Fall Apart in ways that are
horrific including we vote in more
government because everybody's afraid
The Barbarians are at the gate yes so we
need something to protect us which then
speeds up things and businesses have
acted poorly you know religions the
Catholic church has not fully come to
terms with a massive scandal you know
and it's like of course that that erode
social trust and confidence you trust
people less unless you go out less and
less you know it's a Thousand Cuts yeah
and we need to you know kind of have a
Renaissance not of stupidity of just
like okay blind trust but how do we
build up new institutions and how do we
Salvage the ones that are going to
persist I think I know part of the
answer but I love this metaphor though
of a death by a Thousand Cuts you know
versus a thousand points of light right
I mean that's those two things fit hand
and glove but geez I think I think
five years ago
who is the doctor that Kennedy talked
about that Rogan invited to come back
and debate uh Peter Hotes Hotes okay
five years ago had Peter Hotes said look
I'm an expert I'm a doctor I've
litigated this I've looked at this I'm
not going to dignify it
I think a lot of people probably would
have nodded and said uh okay
today
I feel like that guy didn't get the memo
yeah right we just lived through an
incredible time when a lot of very
certain sounding people
made a lot of very dogmatic
proclamations that turned out to be dead
wrong without reservation and this week
don't wear a mask next week wear a mask
the following week and maybe wear a mask
right it's like me I'm a narrator I'm
paid to sound certain so when I narrate
How the Universe works and tell you that
there are 200 billion known galaxies in
the universe I sound like I sound now
and two weeks later when they call me
back in to reread it because as it turns
out they're two trillion yeah right not
a typo but new tech new numbers right I
sound the same right I sound exactly the
same as when I'm off by 2 trillion as I
do when I'm right
so does the president
so does hotels yeah so does Joe Rogan so
does Robert Kennedy Jr so this whole
love affair with certainty and this
whole thing that that that Sam Harris
was saying it's like you guys have to
understand that there is no good will
Left Right reasonable people who Embrace
a level of skepticism that I personally
espouse
I have every right to look at your
credentials and go
persuade me right so I want hotels or
somebody to step up and that's my answer
to your question we're in a funk because
the rug has been pulled out from under
the expert class and the experts are not
making a fundamentally persuasive case
for the rest of us instead they and
their apologists are saying we're not
going to dignify that with the debate
well I'm sorry I don't think that plays
in Peoria anymore not today
that sounded certain that's a very good
uh note to end on I think I I think
you're absolutely correct and that it
isn't you know there are ways to rebuild
trust and confidence we do this
individually in our lives all the time
yes we can do it societally we can do it
in our institutions it's you know in the
beginning of that Turner and I think in
comes in acknowledging the limits of our
knowledge and when we're wrong and then
how do we go about doing a better job
and look you play a role in this Nick I
mean I I really I know in driving down
trust and confidence in almost
everything no look I mean when you talk
about sub stack and you talk about you
know the guys we mentioned and the women
reason is an organ you know re it's it's
it's an opportunity because people are
going to look I think uh for for
something that that feels I don't know
if it's honest we're authentic but
the tribes need to hear the truth from
their own tribesmen and that's what I
meant before here we are here I am
encouraging a more skeptical worldview
at a time when experts are telling me
don't be skeptical just still take our
word for it yeah that is a recipe for
for some kind of collision yeah yeah and
I see you know this is also a whole
other Galaxy to talk about but you know
we're living in an age of forced
transparency yeah where the truth is
going to come out whether you like it or
not you might as well get ahead of it
and just kind of admit what you know and
what you don't know what you're not
certainly sure about Etc and get on with
figuring out how to how to live a better
more interesting life I just want to
tell you about Steve Forbes yes please
who's outside okay
so like 10 years by the way don't give
him any cash he just spends it on booze
well I'll tell you what else he did he
says he wants to buy a hot dog but he
doesn't ten years ago I really showed my
slip and wrote some invective about The
Madness of ranking the top universities
year after year after year again and
again and again it's like what a what a
ridiculous bit of Kabuki this is but if
we're gonna do it how come nobody ever
rates the best trade schools well Forbes
Magazine
printed a lot of what I spewed up and
said micro has a point and ever since
they've been ranking the top 30 trade
schools and that's a hopeful note to end
on because that's it in my world that's
part of what what has to happen although
he always still puts Princeton at the
top because that's where he went you
know what some of my favorite welders
came out of for instance talented women
thank you so much really fun appreciate
it
[Music]